hey bro listen I was trying to buy this
handcrafted mahogany wood model of b-25
mitchell Panchito aircraft for me don't
sass me and I went to this website and
this ad popped up that said hey Ron
Swanson check out this great offer
what's your question my question is what
the hell like how do they know who you
are
yeah okay um there are these things
called cookies where like if you go to a
site buy something it'll remember you
and then create ads for other stuff you
might want to buy so it learns
information about me seems like an
invasion of privacy dude if you think
that's bad go to Google Earth and type
in your address
so we've been called out to this hiking
trail because there's some reports that
some teenagers are digging bags of dog
poop out of the trash and have a dog who
fights I don't believe it
oh my god it's real yeah I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna go deal with this I'm
leaving hey hey hello boys I am Leslie
Knope I work for the Department of Parks
okay okay this is a little fun this is
fun
so while they repaint the lines in the
parking lot we're asking everyone to do
street parking
I'm not street parking my Mercedes well
everyone is I'm doing it because nobody
wants to steal a Saturn all right
moving on to recycling you okay run just
a little tooth pain I'm fine
continue okay each department will be
getting blue bins do you need to go to
the dentist Ron I don't like dentists
just a second I'm sorry everybody what
were we talking about recycling dentist
pulled the tooth out yesterday but it's
always a good idea to demonstrate to
your co-workers that you are capable of
withstanding a tremendous amount of pain
plus it's always fun to see Tom faint
okay here's the situation your parents
went away on a week's vacation they left
the keys to the brand-new Porsche okay
mine well of course not I'll just take
it for a little spin and maybe show it
off to couple the friends
I'll just cruise around the neighborhood
I shouldn't yeah of course I should pay
attention here's the thick of the plot
pulled up to the corner at the end of my
block that's when I saw this beautiful
girly girl walk and I picked up my car
phone to perpetrate like I was talking
sunroof is open the music was high and
that girls hand was steadily moving up
my thought she had opened up three
buttons on her shirt so far I guess
that's why I didn't notice that police
car I can't believe it I made a mistake
my parents are the same no matter time
nor place so to all your kids all across
the land no need to argue parents just
don't understand something I know so
what's up someone is on fire and Rams at
park they need you to get down there
right away oh my god well one of the
funner things that we do here in Pawnee
is the annual Easter egg hunt
Tom hides the eggs and I have to say he
did an exceptional job this year
I've been searching for 25 minutes and I
haven't found a single egg and I'm an
adult oh yeah I forgot to do that maybe
Tom's trying to make this year a
challenge and if so he's he's succeeding
I don't think a single egg has been
found yet
let's keep looking we're gonna find one
welcome to manual control let me show
you around those are some chairs that's
a cat or a possum oh this is a napkin
where I wrote down a cool name for a dog
bark Obama right is that what's
happening here oh yeah yeah we found
this bird outside we tried to turn it
into a work whistle like in the
beginning of the Flintstones tougher
than a look though we have a massive
pest problem in this town and it's
because the Animal Control Department
has been a disaster at catching animals
they're great at ingesting and selling
marijuana this place is a miserable suck
hole run by two pothead losers it's
completely and utterly mismanaged thanks
it does seem to be very poorly run but
we've only been here for two minutes
there may be a method to their madness
there's more than one way to skin a cat
four there's four ways it's gonna care
yeah we got like a huge vermin problem I
mean who wouldn't be meaning to call
somebody about a bug you know nobody get
on the phone you're the people you would
be calling trippy oh you're fired you're
fired the whole department is fine how
this
this was one of my running feet yeah
let's go to Jamaica no we should go to
Jamaica okay what'd you say is the coast
clear
what are you wearing I sneak around
close is he gone
yeah he's gone come in you gotta see
this Tom and I have been seeing each
other for a few weeks and I think I'm
ready to say I love you to his apartment
I love you so much
look at all these blankets one on the
Ottoman one on the chair one of the
couch here yeah holy hell that soft oh
oh my god is that yep a whole shelf of
coconut water I think I'm gonna cry this
is like girl heaven did he do all of
this just for you no he just lives like
this
he's deeply in debt but you know what
who cares check it out
cheese plate and Adriatic figs Leslie
this is always here I don't know when he
has time to make it Boutique eye cream
unisex cologne lip exfoliator
chocolate-covered almonds and Sudoku
book just amenities everywhere I love
amenity you know check this out that's
the best part 80 degrees night and day
God get this one there's another soft
one good morning whoa Swiss Family
Robinson that hat is dope
thanks Tom you mind if I rock that bad
Larry on my dome wear it on my head
try it on the leis be my guest
hi I'm Tom I have a raccoon on my head
excuse me my friend over here was
digging through your trash and I think
we may have a lot in common
I'm Tom would you like to see a movie
something are you a raccoon because
you've been running around my hat all
day head all day girl you're more
precious than precious nice hat want a
bone that's you talking to me no how
about yes I am a hunter and it's you
season whoa that's great I gotta get
back out there you know what they say
animal on the head man
in the bed damn girl your hotness kill
my raccoon I have a raccoon hat I'm an
interesting person hello
any luck no didn't work out as well as I
thought I would yeah better luck next
time I tried just doesn't seem well I
love that hat thank you ma'am
now after we are given the certificate
who do you think should speak first I
think it should be me and then you but
if you want it could be you and then me
or it could go me you me what do you
think about just you thank you Ron yes
tomorrow the Parks and Rec Department is
receiving a commendation at the Indiana
State House for bringing the harvest
festival back and although it's purely
ceremonial it's a huge deal for me to go
to the Statehouse I couldn't care less
about the commendation
but Indianapolis is home to Charles
Mulligan's Steakhouse the best damn
Steakhouse in the damn State I have
taken a picture of every steak I've ever
eaten there June 2004 porterhouse
medium-rare Bearnaise sauce January 2000
they call this one the enforcer February
96 a steak ribeye the whiskey Lagavulin
16 the lady next to me a [ __ ]
specifically my ex-wife Tammy okay this
is this is the first time I ever went
there gonna be just a kid
you